[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum i hope you guys had a
glorious week
or uh you're having a good week thanks
for listening and tuning into the
podcast ryan always good to see you
good to see you as well right before we
get on the air we're talking about
pounding alcohol and i'm not a pounder
and
nort nor are you uh no i'm not a pounder
but i
uh i guess i'm a marathoner you like to
drink for long periods of time at night
like you start early and you're the one
who drinks till two in the morning yeah
yeah i can do that i can't do that i
drank probably about eight o'clock at
night and buy three drinks by about nine
i want everybody the [ __ ] out of my
house
by nine by nine well ten maybe because i
just feel guilty or feel like an old man
my
friends call me gramps oh by then the
after party started so that's okay
yeah let them go after party i just
never had it in me i mean maybe in
college i stuck around and like you know
you see what happens but what's the
point of staying up so late uh-huh
finding somebody else drunk to hook up
with i think so that's why you do it
yeah yeah i don't know if that's such a
good idea
hey thanks for listening um you know
ryan why don't you tell them the handles
if you guys want to if
you're here for sophia bush it's a we're
going to get right into it but um
we really do appreciate if you if you if
you enjoy the interview hopefully you're
going to stick around
and hear the handles uh inside of you
pod on twitter inside of your podcast on
instagram and
facebook that is correct and uh you can
subscribe you can watch it on youtube
which is always great um ryan is
an amazing editor the shows look
fantastic
and uh you could also listen to it where
wherever stitcher apple
all that stuff we really appreciate that
and thanks for all the kind words i had
covered
and uh i'm over it now and tested
negative
and feeling a little bit back to myself
but i don't have any taste or smell
it's the real deal it's uh it sucks
you've never had any taste
oh real dick move ryan
real dick move post coven i gotta hear
that it was right there
it was right there it was right there
for the taking uh well first of all make
sure you join patreon if you want to
support the podcast which we love your
support and it really helps the podcast
go to patreon.com
inside of you um and uh there's a bunch
of perks
of joining and becoming part of the big
family of patreon patreon.com inside of
you
and also if you want any merch lex
luthor stuffs marvel stuff inside of
your stuff go to the inside of you
online store
somehow my dog blanche is in here even
though ryan thought he
locked her out hi blanche well she's
having a seat all right that's fine you
could hear her jingle she's good let's
uh
get into this guest you know this was a
fun guest um i really enjoyed having
sophia bush here
in the studio we were both vaxxed and
then i felt bad because then i
tested positive and i had to call her
and say oh [ __ ] but she's good to go and
um it was kind of uh you know you just
got to be transparent say [ __ ] i don't
know what to tell you i
just found this out i got a text and uh
[ __ ]
but uh you know you know from one tree
hill but she's been in a ton of stuff
um false positive is a movie on netflix
which is really dark and she was a great
guest she's so articulate
um i was intimidated by her ryan yeah
yeah i just thought
oh you know she's a beautiful woman and
she's very
intelligent and she's perfect for not me
because uh i think uh she's probably too
smart for me but she's too smart
no you are a smart person well i just
felt a little like you know she's got
so much going on that i would probably
bore her even though i find myself to be
somewhat amusing
not that i'm even all i'm saying is that
that when i was interviewing her
like wow this is a this is a real woman
here this is a
i really i just really liked her she's
amazing um
it's an amazing interview um i think i
got under nerves once but
i think that's par for the course but uh
it was a great interview so
why don't we step right into it let's
get inside of sophia
bush it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
so you come over you immediately play
with my dog
blanche and within five seconds she
knocks over your entire full cup of iced
coffee
yeah all over the living room yeah and
then you proceed to help me clean it up
obviously i brought it over then you
train my dog
i just needed to you know
be her camp counselor for a minute calm
her down like bring her energy down make
her feel safe
post coffee disaster can you do that
with humans too
uh i've been told yes i
i have that vibe i i'm one of the people
who always winds up hearing everyone's
deepest darkest secrets and problems
people believe they can confide in you
is that what you're saying yeah
why is that is that you do have a
certain voice doesn't she have a voice
ryan
we put the mic up for god's sakes cause
then we can't hear your voice
right she has this soothing voice do you
do a lot of voiceover work
interestingly not as much as you would
think
really because it's very unique i could
see you playing even a teenager of like
like kind of like a parker what's the
show
not parker lewis can't wait pinky
brewster punky bruce hunky brewster
monkey brewster big mouth any of the fun
stuff well you did incredibles too
i did well how much fun was that the bet
i mean just the best
i also and you and you'll know the
feeling i i was
at a lunch with friends you know this
was pre-pandemic when we still ate
inside
and i was at a lunch with friends uh in
venice
and my agent called and was like what is
the matter with you why have you not
responded to me today and i was like
what are you talking about first of all
i don't look at email so
what do you mean no i hate it i think
email is archaic and torturous and i
can't believe no one has developed a
better user interface but that's a
separate conversation
and so i open the email and there's a p
it's just a pdf
and so i open the pdf and it's a letter
on incredibles letterhead from brad bird
asking me to play void and i
screamed at a pitch that i didn't know
my voice could make i thought i lost
that at like eight
that level of high you just let it go
it just happened and the whole
restaurant turned and i just went i'm so
sorry it's really good news
did everybody laugh or they were just no
some people were laughing and like a
couple people
when i left were like what was what
happened what's the news
but that's exciting though incredibles 2
you played void
yeah like i've done a lot of voiceover
work and did you find it
nerve-racking were you acting with other
actors were you shooting by yourself or
what did you do how'd you do it um i
didn't find it nerve-wracking
what i what was really interesting
and how fun as an adult to be really
surprised
right what was really interesting to me
was
figuring out how to create
a sound to go along with something that
doesn't exist
oh yeah because they hadn't showed you
did they show you any examples or like
little drawings
my animation wasn't done yet i had
drawings but
you know i was in the booth with brad
which is the most incredible thing i was
like please do edna
okay please do another voice okay okay
okay do this one now and he was like
we're here to record you
ma'am um but it was really fun
to get to play with a writer director of
that
caliber and and also
to feel free enough in the room when
he'd say okay you're gonna jump
uh you know from the stoop to the
sidewalk off of let's say six stairs
you gotta land we need the sound of you
landing okay fine
okay but what happens when you jump off
a hundred story building and land
i have no idea what that sounds like
right so we had to just come up with
things and
and it was fun in moments what's the
sound effect for jumping off of the
stoop
just the small version i mean you how
would you land
i'm going to ask you yeah
you know a little breath because you get
the wind slightly knocked out
try it oh you just coughed that sounded
like a cough
that didn't sound good when was your
last negative pcr mine was yesterday
great same i tested negative yesterday
because i was feeling low energy because
i was just tired
so i was like i got it i must have it i
had to do a shoot this morning so i
tested tuesday and yesterday really
which actually gave me a lot of peace of
mind given the
you know current what did you shoot uh i
had to do a shoot for a lure
oh that's a fancy magazine lures never
called me
they're very famous it's female right i
mean i think largely
you were also um maxim's top 100 back in
the day
not that far ago fargo fargo
great movie how good is kirsten dunst on
fargo i only saw season
one she's so good i would have seen her
did i
yeah no take this part out of the
podcast yes
now i won't take it out i only saw
season one of fargo kirsten dunst isn't
it yes
wait a minute then i just didn't
recognize her you might you also might
have thought you saw season one and you
didn't well
which one was season one it was with the
guy the really quirky guy
season one was with colin hanks yes yeah
so oh did she start in season two i
think i'm wrong i'm right i think season
season two i was so sure maybe we should
edit it now all right you know what
we're not we don't need to talk about
fargo
anymore it's just a great show is the
point it is a great so
i was talking about uh the top hundred
maxim because you know as you can see up
there
back in the day i was 100 top 50
most eligible bachelors i don't know how
they determine that and why is my
picture drinking a glass of milk
i don't know do you see it i don't know
either it's just really weird i don't
get it photo in a diner though i really
do
yes but do you hate shoot doing shoots
like that
being pretty and glamorous and stuff
like that or do you ever feel real
comfortable
you just go with it you just it's part
of the job i mean i always feel awkward
with life in general yeah and like
getting my picture taken everyone
assumes you're good at that if you
are an entertainer but i immediately i'm
like but what is my body
where do my arms go like i've never
gotten
relaxed about that um
and you know there are times in your
life
where people
pressure you to to do things that you
may not have wanted to do um
like a shoot or whatever totally so i
would always much
rather do the cool editorial thing
you know strange fashion stuff that
feels more like a character
um i mean your diner photo like oh man
if there were a place that i could do a
shoot i think i'd want to shoot in russ
and daughters in new york
what's that oh like the best deli around
so you'd like to shoot in a deli
something charactery something cool
i'd be so happy so doing something and i
could get snacks on the way home
i could get a pastrami to go it would be
great so but doing something like a lure
you're saying is a little bit more
it's it's it's what's the word i'm
thinking it's everybody's tense it's
like got to be great it's got to be
we've got to capture beauty and just
elegance i didn't feel tense this
morning i just kept laughing
i kept interrupting myself and being
like what am i doing i don't know what
i'm doing
is this is any of this good is this what
you're asking for i
i have no idea um and
i think what's nice at least about this
sort of moment in my life
is that i'm less nervous to admit i have
no [ __ ] idea what's going on
like when i showed up on my first you
know full-time set at 21
i was like oh my god okay that was one
tree hill yeah at 21.
21. i knew it was young i knew you had
to be up and i was like i don't know
what i'm doing
i just kind of like learned what a mark
was recently and um
i'm just gonna pretend like i know what
they're talking about and i'll learn
and and you do you learn quickly but i
think
for me reflecting and being able to
reflect with you know my
co-stars about that you you get
sort of adultified in ways you don't
realize when you're young
and and looking back i wish we'd had
more of a
you know a young cast person
uh mentor in the production department
situation but we didn't help you out
because you're saying is that
they're sort of like an allure
no but but there's sort of this
idea that you have to people need to see
you as confident yeah they need to see
you as you know what you're doing
and well or if you if you don't know
what you're doing are you unprofessional
are you wasting people's time do you
deserve to be here
those are all the fears we carry which
are
bogus but that doesn't mean we don't
worry about them
i can't imagine getting fame at 21 being
a lead on a show you're one of the leads
and i
i don't think i you know it happened
really till i was
27 or 26 but i'm very immature i think
i've always been
incredibly immature and you seem like
you are very mature
like with your activism and all these
things you're beyond your years i really
believe that don't you think so
that's really nice i mean i yeah i've
always kind of been a little old person
like even as a little kid i was where
does that stem from i don't know
but i remember i saw this video of
myself on a camping trip with my dad and
my grandpa
and i was talking to the two of them and
i sound
like jack lemmon in grumpy old men and
i'm like well you know what would be a
hoot and i'm like what
seven-year-old said that like i have no
idea where i got it what was happening
yeah i i kind of feel like um
like i've always been grown up
but i feel the old soul energy if that's
the right term
more for us for humanity for a
collective
the activism the the work on behalf of a
community has always made sense to me
and then i think the you know pervasive
anxiety about not knowing the answer or
perhaps
um desire to be as professional as
possible
all stems from a very young you know
well of self-doubt and fear and
and that's is kind of an interesting
dichotomy when people say to me you seem
confident i'm confident for us
i'm not very confident as an individual
but i just choose to kind of like not
pay attention to that part and do the
rest
well your parents always about doing the
right thing did they instill that
in you at a very young age were they
always were they not maybe
activists but always talking about the
right things or
do they have beliefs that you don't kind
of share you know it's interesting
i think the thing i respect so much
about my parents
is that they even in their 70s
are very willing to inquire where their
beliefs come from
i've watched my dad get so progressive
and
recently we were talking about it and i
was complimenting you know things he
sends me and
and just saying you know how much i love
seeing a man of
you know his age um
seeming to learn all these things and my
dad looked at me and was like
oh do you not know we were out
protesting vietnam do you not know
and i learned all these things about my
parents before i was born
that i'm like oh they never shared that
with you
and maybe they did but i you know what
does a kid remember i don't know
right maybe maybe they shared some of
that stuff with me when i was just young
enough that it didn't
entrench itself in my memory um but
you know really just really cool to hear
them
talk about their upbringings and there
were things i knew
you know i knew about my dad's story
immigrating to america and
how long it took him to you know get his
green card and become a citizen and i
understand how tough that is how long
did it take him um
well my dad came in the 60s and he
didn't become a citizen until i was 12
and i was born in 82 so that would have
been 94.
wow so it takes a long time isn't that
crazy
and you know my mom my mom's mom
came to america on a boat through ellis
island
and my mom grew up in a housing project
in the bronx
and you know she was
exposed to so many of the things that
i've leaned into in my activism
um in terms of communities that are
disenfranchised and
uh and it's really interesting now
you know i'll tell her about something
and she's like yeah i know and then she
talks about something
from her childhood and i'm going wow
this is a this is a wild sort of full
circle
experience yeah were they always
supportive like when you
went off to college i read this thing
i'm sure you've talked about it but
where you were you loved volleyball
you're playing volleyball
and yeah this school makes you audition
for a play
or you have to be in a play we had arts
requirements in middle school
arts requirements in middle school this
is middle school we're talking about
middle school i went to the most
phenomenal middle school in high school
and there were four semesters of arts
requirements in seventh and eighth grade
and i was like i don't do pla my friend
does plays
so you were upset at first yeah i was
kind of like i don't care about it i'm
going to go to medical school i'm going
to be a heart surgeon like
this you want to be a heart surgeon that
was my plan and so i thought you know
being like a smart
goofy kid i was like well if i do my
play second semester of eighth grade
that's spring season that's volleyball
you know so i won't have to do it
because i'm gonna play volleyball
and the school was like you chose this
this is your choice
you you had the freedom to uh do your
play last semester and do ceramics this
semester and you didn't
so you're doing a play and i remember
just thinking it was
so stupid the play
just the whole the idea of doing it what
play was it
uh it was our town our town yeah sure a
very famous one that every high school
college everyone does and it's so good
yeah and what was really interesting to
me was that
i realized in real time that we were
bringing a book to life essentially and
it just changed my whole view
of everything and i realized you know
the reason that i can't ever give a book
to anyone because they're underlined and
dog-eared and noted in the margins and
i love reading and learning and here was
a book come to life and i leaned into
theater really hard all through high
school
and just loved it so much and got so
nerdy like
in the ways that i was such a little kid
and sort of
sheltered for a long time i was also
such an old man
i started doing research about you know
um the
traditions of human story pre the
written word and was like
i was in high school and just so you're
doing this in high school i'm
practically failing out yeah while she's
looking up this
and i was like this is how humanity came
to be before we could write things down
we would do plays for each other this is
why we know things
i i really get fired up about
nerdy stuff but wait a minute so the
play
did you have a big part in the play no
small part
yeah and through high school i did leads
and plays i
tech plays i was a prop master on many
plays i
i played supporting roles in plays i
mean it was yeah
i was like behind the scenes i was doing
lighting oh i love it i'm the
prop master i'm the problem i'm the
master of all props
we don't we don't use that word anymore
i assume now we say properties manager
um oh
oh man i just loved it you fell in love
with it yeah
and you said i don't want to be a heart
surgeon anymore i want to be an actor
yeah so imagine going to my immigrant
father and my daughter of an immigrant
mother
and saying so mom and dad i don't think
i'm gonna go to medical school
i'm gonna go to the theater they were
just
pissed horrified did they see you in a
play that they see you in place at this
point
so they were like she's good yeah but
but
my mom was just like that's not a a
real stable life you can't do
that what are you doing yeah and it is
crazy what we do
um but my parents
my dad um prior to retiring a couple
years ago
was a advertising photographer and you
know he is a creative
and they told me years later that they
had this conversation
after i had this talk with them about
going to you know get a bfa
instead of a medical degree and my mom
was like this is all your fault
you turned your hobby into your career
and now she thinks she can do it too
you know she was just so nervous for me
um
because your dad's a photographer
photographer of what
he did you know advertising celebrity
beauty campaigns like
really yeah did he ever shoot you mm-hmm
he did yeah i had somebody
do my headshots for free for you know 20
years and then were they good
yeah i mean my dad was like doing
campaigns for neutrogena and
has been published in vogue he's wildly
talented
that's exciting and just so nice he's a
nice guy
my dad's really nice there's a lot of
people in that world who aren't
nice and he yeah
inside of you is brought to you by nitsa
it's a fact that a child's body
temperature
rises three to five times faster than
adults
and leaving a child in a hot vehicle can
lead to their death very
quickly sadly in 2020
24 children died of pediatric vehicular
heat stroke and many of these incidents
occurred when parents or caregivers
simply forgot the child was in the car
unintentionally leaving a child in a car
is a tragedy that can happen to anyone
please set yourself reminders on your
cell phone or place something you'll
need in the back seat to help you
remember
that your child is still in the car if
your partner or caregiver is taking your
child to daycare check with them
or the child care staff to make sure
that the child was dropped off
and when you've arrived at your
destination always check to make sure
the car
is empty heat stroke deaths are
preventable when adults take the proper
precautions
be safe and always look for your baby
before you lock
paid for by nitsa inside of you is
brought to you by helix sleep i don't
know about you ryan but uh what's the
most important part of uh
your day or night well it's sleep with
closely followed by breakfast but it's
definitely sleep
sleep because what do we do mostly in
our lives we spend most of our life
sleeping
that's absolutely right and if you're
not staying in a sleeping in a bed
that's comfortable
and not getting a good night's rest what
you're not going to be
you're at your best it's just i mean
these are this is just
obvious folks uh helix sleep is just
remarkable they're a great company
and it's so simple helix sleep has a
quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else you shouldn't why would you
right
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way
you sleep and everybody's unique and
helix knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot
and even a helix plus mattress for plus
size sleepers
i got the medium it's like the porridge
for me i don't like things too
you know hard i don't like things too
soft right there in the middle that's
where i get the best sleep
and uh they just uh they're pretty
incredible helix sleep and i really
thank them and
uh it's been awesome getting messages
from so many of you who also found that
helix mattress
really works for you and you found the
mattress of your dreams so if you're
looking for a mattress just take a quiz
order the mattress that you're matched
to and the mattress comes right to your
door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by gq and wired magazine
and all you have to do is go to helix
h-e-l-i-x
sleep helix sleep.com inside
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep
of your life and these guys got a
10-year warranty
you try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep.com
inside that's helixsleep.com
inside for up to 200 off and two
free pillows helix sleep
when you date someone do you look at
your father
as sort of the guy like you know you
don't want to date your father you hear
that you know a lot of times but you
your father you talk about him so
pleasantly i mean
he's in he's a nice guy do you usually
date nice guys
or do you go the opposite have you gone
to the i'm sure you have gone the
opposite for
you know a few times i look i'm not
attracted to [ __ ]
right but i do think that where again a
lot of my wisdom
for us you know for a community exists
yes i think uh in the same way that i've
lacked some confidence
on the individual side i've lacked a bit
of discernment
or perhaps having a like a [ __ ]
meter
in my personal life so i've dated some
people who i thought were really nice
who were not
what is that though do you think that's
a lesson it's a lesson but don't you
think there is
sort of this feeling you have when
you're on set
and you meet someone and there's an
attraction to his
his or her uh talent are you attracted
to talent are you
more attracted to i don't know about if
i would put it that way i'm attracted to
uh you know creativity to ambition to
intellect
to service um i also think
and i'd be curious about your
experiences there i think there's like a
very
it's funny because you realize that
everybody you've ever ma
met in this business has like dated
everybody else
and you know when you when you spend 100
hours a week
on set and you literally you don't even
get home for eight hours to sleep
like yeah i'm not surprised that every
20 year old on a set has dated every
other 20 year old on a set right
who cares this is your family this is
your life you don't know much but it's
like
i don't know we we act like it's not
common and it's wildly common
and you know some of our favorite like
quote-unquote celebrity couples are like
people who married the fourth co-star
they dated like i don't know
right i don't particularly care about
anybody's personal life so long as
it's not like disruptive to work but i
do
think there's just a
a thing that happens to a lot of people
whereby
as you get older and you get more
stability
outside of work that
you know your just your perspective
changes i mean how does it work for you
the more i'm just immersed in work
the more i'm just hyper focused the less
happy i am
i'm and i'm learning that as i get older
and older like this can't you can't be
thinking about this all the time you
have to
disconnect you have to take a trip you
explore you have to educate yourself
whatever it is because i mean for many
years i think i was just
so you know i'm on set i'm
this is this is who i am this is this is
my world but
it's a different scenario and i've
talked about on the podcast before
because i i
for me it was somebody who didn't have
confidence didn't have the uh
i did some i did a play somewhat they i
i was good
somebody said you're really good mm-hmm
you're really funny
and also i'm like oh i'm funny this
person thinks i'm funny i need to just
be on stage all the time so i was about
finding myself i think my journey really
just trying to find out who i really am
yeah because i didn't know who i was and
i
mm-hmm well i think that that
especially when you are working young
what a what an easy pit to fall into
because you're figuring out who the
people you play are and you're supposed
to figure out who you are
and and your experiences can are
conveyed on screen but if you don't have
a lot of experiences because you're
young and you're looking for them
and yeah it's a conundrum indeed and i
think
you know when you when you mix all of
that reality and with the fact that
you're performing
if you're on a show like you know the
ones we used to be on you're working 16
or 17 hours a day
yeah your whole life revolves around the
people you're
around i know and so it's like i get it
you know i've been that young person and
i give advice to a lot of young people
in the same positions
and the thing i always try to say is i
understand why you're trying to build a
home where you are
you know i think especially for me and
and many of my friends who
were in similar positions to me when we
talk about it
now you realize when you pick up and you
move away from home
and you literally you don't see anyone
except the people you work with for 10
months a year
i'm like i get it you want to build a
home you want to feel
like it was worth it to leave everyone
you love
and to be away from your family and
your parents and to miss weddings and
birthdays and
you know people having babies and i get
it
you really want to build and cultivate a
real you know work family and
sense of home i get it i'm also just
very deeply committed to my real home
at this stage in my life i mean i have
to be
so difficult for you to be 21 years old
and as a lead on a show
getting started and it's just it's over
probably overwhelming
right oh yeah in a lot of ways yeah and
and for me
especially going to do that kind of show
you know going back to high school after
only three years in college
right and doing a version of high school
that i'd only heard about i went to an
all-girls school
right i didn't have one iota
of experience with boys being in class
with bad guys who'd lie to you with
dramatic
you know girls fighting over boys in
school and i didn't have
any of that but you just learned to act
through it well you have to that's your
job
but it you know god what a i mean what a
crazy what a crazy ride we went on it
was hilarious how
soon after you started one tree hill did
you
well you had already met chad michael
murray but oh i'm not gonna
talk about you don't talk about that
i'm not allowed to because i've tried to
poke fun
at being a dumb kid right that's what
i'm
whenever i've done that it gets twisted
into i'm talking [ __ ] about somebody
who i don't even know anymore who's
clearly a grown-up like
right but i'm i i think
you have to like laugh at who you used
to be but when people ask me about
um history that involves someone else
right
i unfortunately like i just well it's
not even unfortunate
it's just not work it's not worth my
time right it's not a place where i
harbor
um you know ill will or
and it can't come out right it never
does right right
and i've tried to like you know do the
thing where when i get stuck
uh live on the air which has happened to
me twice
getting asked about it where i like give
a little like huh like jazz hands quip
and move on
and it doesn't it just doesn't work so
i'm not going to i
i you know i was a very um
naive 21 year old kid and that's all
there is
but you did say something that i read
about i knew that i was getting into
and i and i will always believe in love
oh god i probably said that in my 20s
when i was just trying to keep everybody
happy well i think that you
you said something where you want when
you got married you go and get married
because you think you're gonna be
married once
michael we're not really gonna talk
about this are we no i'm just thinking i
think that though that's why i'm single
the reason i brought it up hear me out
okay is because i think
i've seen so much dysfunction in my
family you have it maybe i think every
family has seen and i i've seen extreme
dysfunction
dysfunction my sister is married five
times wow mother of three times
a lot of different things so i feel that
[ __ ] man i'm not getting married until
it's the one
and that might sound naive but that's
why i think i've waited so long
yeah i get that but you know what i
think
look i think lots of people do stupid
[ __ ] before their prefrontal cortexes
are fully formed and they're not until
they're 26.
right so you do the math on my timeline
i literally didn't have a whole brain
so i have like humor and grace for like
being a kid and you know
having the experience that i had but but
i also think
we're at a really interesting time where
we're look we're looking at systems in
general
and marriage uh i learned so much about
it reading elizabeth gilbert's book
committed
and one of the things i thought was so
interesting and i read it years ago so i
won't have the facts perfect for you
which i like too but here we are but she
essentially talks about how
early or there's early evidence of the
church trying to ban marriage
because you were not as you know a
member of the faithful
supposed to be devoted to anyone but god
and then they realized they couldn't
keep people from getting married
people in villages and towns were just
doing this thing so then they said
the only recognized marriage is in the
church so
we have to look at what our motivations
are what the politics are
um churches by the way are so political
it's crazy to me they don't pay taxes
again separate conversation
um but you know it used to be
that the the person on this farm and the
person on this farm would get married so
they could join farms and there was a
dowry and somebody got like
livestock and like really weird
patriarchal nonsense
and now we're in this time where as many
if not more women in
our country anyway are the breadwinners
of their household
people want to build families they want
to have kids they want to have
these experiences that i think we all
deeply
romanticize and you look at a divorce
rate of over 50 percent
it's really complicated um you know it's
something like and this was a stat i
read a few years ago
so i'd be curious to know if the numbers
are the same now but 72 percent of men
cheat on their wives
followed by 41 wait how many 72 percent
of men cheat on their own if i remember
the stat correctly and followed by and
growing 41
of women who are now cheating on their
husbands i know we're just talking about
heteronormative relationships but that's
the stat that i read
and that number is growing as more and
more women
become the economic leaders of their
households
and so i think overall
we have to have a much more real
conversation
as a society and within our own romantic
relationships and
our friendships with you know our
friends who are likely in romantic
relationships of their own
what are our motivations like what are
we looking for
i i grew up on disney movies and
watching rom-coms and went to an
all-girls school
i was the prime like right out of the
cartoon factory candidate for like a
fairy tale ideal of young love come on
like it wrote itself
but really now as an adult and for you
in this position where you're saying you
have your own skittishness and
nervousness about really diving in
um i imagine that you have trust issues
and also feel really nervous
truly opening up and being your full
self with someone god you're good
thank you okay so how do we begin to
unpack these things for each other
and figure out like what is your
motivation is your
saying well i want to make sure it's
absolutely the one is that actually just
an avoidance tactic to
prevent being intimate with anybody
god i knew this would turn around on me
yeah it probably is it's a defensive
defense mechanism i think i mean because
there's no perfect
one out there there's just they don't
exist i'm not perfect and neither are
you
well you're closer than i am you're very
kind perfection
uh and ryan here but um well ryan's
obviously perfect except for the fact
that he doesn't know how to use a
microphone
yeah exactly this is accurate
[Laughter]
um i i i don't know but let me ask you
what
what is now going from this 21 year old
girl really girl to this whatever
how do you feel about it how do you feel
about marriage how do you feel about
i mean do you want to get married
largely i feel great about it
but again i think it depends on what
people's motivations are
and i want to make sure whether it's
myself or one of my best friends
that we're clear on what it is we're
signing up for
rather than thinking we're getting some
like you know
kate hudson and matt mcconaughey uh
rom-com
life you know this notion that you're
going to meet your person
and they're going to make you so happy
that you're going to be fulfilled
and you'll never be nervous again and
you'll never ever think anyone else is
hot
like what it's such an absurd
uh joke and so what i
am a fan of when i'm a believer in is
real partnership real
intimacy that comes with radical honesty
and
with ground rules of always giving your
partner the benefit of the doubt
while asking questions while
being able to be vulnerable admit when
you're afraid admit when you're being
triggered by something else
like you have to do a lot of work that
sounds
i mean it sounds the first thing i
thought of was this needs to be a course
in college
oh i agree seriously they would just
really sit down and talk to you about
look these are the things
and i think earlier i had a really
fascinating conversation with esther
perel who was talking about certain
countries
um that begin empathy education
in preschool and every couple of years
there's more curriculum
which is about um holding space for each
other
and what what consent means we don't hit
our classmates if you want to hug
someone ask those kinds of things for
little kids
that steadily evolve into sex ed in you
know whether it's middle school high
school i don't know when they do that
for
kids anymore um clearly we're doing a
terrible job of it
uh so that it's it is about consent it
is about
intimacy it is about sexual safety and
and and they learn about
relationship building from the time that
they're
you know for can you imagine if we'd had
14 months oh my god oh my god
you know i just never existed oh i saw i
was surrounded by just dysfunction and i
didn't
so imagine at a young age if you had
because in the developmental years
when you're five seven whatever it is if
you're not receiving love and all these
things that you should be receiving as a
young
kid yeah it changes the whole outcome it
really does and you don't know what that
is and you're
i think that's what a lot of people do
go through i mean unless you have really
great parents and you know
um i don't know it sounds like you had a
great experience with that
i mean my parents and i have done the
work we had years that weren't
great how do you do work with your
parents uh i do a lot of work on my own
and bring my work
home how do you do that though how do
you do you say okay
family meeting yeah you do i started
instituting family meetings about five
years ago
does it include uh maybe the person
you're dating now or is it just
strictly you and your parents um well no
at that at that time and
and for many years it was really about
the three of us and working through some
stuff you know i needed to talk to them
about
experiences i had as a kid and my you
know the vestiges of childhood trauma
that i carry from those things and
and we we all needed to get clear
on certain matters because the reality
is everyone has a memory of an
experience
you know tomorrow each of the three of
us will have a memory from today and
they might be
different and so to be able to sit
mine will be i don't think sophia liked
me as much because i was hoping she
would
yeah i don't think no go ahead um you
know it's
it's really important to
ask people what they remember to share
with them what you remember
and it's very hard it's very hard for me
to say something
this is my experience and my father or
mother whoever
says oh get out of here that's not what
happened at all yeah
what are you talking about i wasn't like
this is an experience i have
that i've kept with me yeah and now
they're just belittling it yeah
i would offer that there's a lot of
power in letting them do that
and just watching it and then saying
okay
so if you want to say to me that that
didn't happen
why is this my memory why is this my
experience why have i gone
through work on this in therapy why do
you think i'm bringing it up to you now
you can really disarm someone's desire
to avoid
their mistakes and you can also offer
the kindness of we've all made mistakes
and i'm not bringing this up with you
because i blame you
i'm bringing it up with you because i
want to heal it between us
that gives me anxiety of course it does
it's killing your [ __ ] anxiety
thinking of having that conversation
with um
it's really certain people hard
but it is i believe
something we all deserve and i think can
be a real
sign of progress and personal growth
when you can just say like okay you all
can flail around me and i'm gonna stand
here
like a concrete post and when you've
tired yourselves out
i'm still going to be holding space to
talk about it it's kind of like
you know i used to be a camp counselor
it's not far off on how you deal with
kids that are throwing temper tantrums
people revert to childish avoidant
selves when they think they're going to
get criticized we all become a
five-year-old who thinks we're going to
the principal's office
you know it's just human tendency and if
you can understand the tendency
you can kind of de-personalize the
response
and frankly you also have to have a
moment i think in your adult self i did
where i finally said i might not ever
get the moment on this
issue that i want from my parents they
may not parent me through
this example in the way that i want them
to
and weirdly as soon as i accepted that
they became the best version of my
parents they've ever been
i've given up i think i think i've given
up on that really
yeah because i i feel like um
they see what they want to see they hear
what they want to hear they
they don't want to acknowledge things
because i think it hurts them and it
embarrasses them
and um it's an old school mentality yeah
maybe that's an excuse
but um i just feel like it's not even
worth it i've had
therapists in the past kind of say well
you should bring this up i'm like you
just don't understand
i i know and they're like you don't
think i deal with people all the time or
i go
i know you do but not this one this is
different
my father's different you know what i
mean and you know
my father actually we have a much better
relationship
in recent years but that was going to be
my next question yeah i kind of wrote
him a letter
i i'm much more articulate as you could
probably tell when i write
i have the time to yeah me too i i don't
get i don't get um
you're very articulate i can be but
sometimes
unless i bring up chad michael murray
jesus flipped out on me
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online therapy
they've been my sponsor for quite some
time and there's a good reason for that
it works
better help works online therapy works
uh it worked ryan you have a you have a
therapist online
yes yeah what does it help you with uh
it is very helpful to have a third party
sort of listen to your stuff and uh
give you some very well-rounded uh
feedback
you said your stuff and you know what's
apparent is everyone has
stuff you don't know you have stuff
until you say stuff until you start
talking about it and uh you know i think
there's a stigma attached with therapy
but i think it's going away because
people are realizing that
talking to an outside party helps them
it really helps them
as we begin to see the light at the end
of the covet tunnel a lot of people are
still feeling down and emotionally out
of sorts
you may not feel depressed or at a total
loss but if you're feeling a little bit
off your
relationships or suffering or you're
just you're feeling off in general
that could be a sign that you should
talk to somebody online therapy
can help it does help all you do it's so
simple you fill out a questionnaire
so betterhelp can assess your needs and
match you with a professional license
therapist start communicating with your
therapist in under 48 hours it's so easy
i'm telling you i can do this
i did it schedule secure weekly video
phone or even live chat appointments
therapists have a broad range of
expertise that may not be locally
available in your area
but all you do is you log into your
account anytime you send a message to
your therapist
betterhelp is committed to great matches
so it's easy
and free to change therapists if needed
and that's important because
you know you meet someone you're just
not vibing with you don't feel
comfortable you change it just like that
with better help online therapy it's
more convenient more affordable than
in-person therapy
speak you're speaking to someone who
knows this clearly it's
way more affordable than in person and
financial aid is available
and check this out our listeners get 10
off their first month
at betterhelp.com inside that's
betterhelp.com
inside get some therapy better help
online therapy inside of you is brought
to you by geico
that's right geico ryan you rent your
apartment i rent my apartment
i own this beautiful house i i do own
the house as of now and
as long as the podcast continues you
know and it's hard it's hard work
definitely paying your mortgage and all
these things
uh but what's easy is bundling policies
honestly with with geico bundling
policies folks it makes it easy to
bundle your homeowners or renters
insurance along with your auto policy
we're so busy nowadays i i don't go to
the grocery store you have things that
you know
you you don't have to you get things
delivered why not do that with your all
your insurance
it's so easy with this bundling policy
you just go to geico.com
you get a quote and you see how much you
can save it's geico easy these guys are
everywhere they know what they're doing
right
visit geico.com today that's geico.com
inside of you is brought to you by
hellofresh
hello fresh i love these guys uh
you know i don't have time to go to the
grocery store and say oh i'm gonna make
this
chicken cacciatore and i'm like what's
in the chicken cacciatore and i have to
buy all these things and
put them together in the right
measurements and what if i told you
there's a company
hello that brings you everything you
need to make your meal
and you'll have this meal prepared in
under 30 minutes a delicious meal
i did this myself i feel so accomplished
after this
and these are delicious healthy meals
healthy for me
this is you know i'm used to ordering
out and this is such an
amazing alternative hellofresh cuts out
stressful meal planning and grocery
store trips
with less prep less effort and minimal
cleanup so you can enjoy cooking and get
dinner on the table
in just about 30 minutes hello freshers
produce gets from the farm to your door
in less than a week which means fresh
high quality ingredients this summer
hellofresh has everything you need to
get grilling and i love grilling
grilling bundles burger packs surf and
turf packs
and hello fresh is 28 cheaper than
shopping at your local grocery store
72 cheaper than a restaurant meal
without sacrificing the quality that's a
sources zagat dining survey so this is
the real deal
pretty amazing stuff here all you have
to do is this go to hellofresh.com
iou14 and use the code iou14
for up to 14 free meals plus
free shipping hellofresh.com
iou14 and use code iou14 for up to 14
free meals plus free shipping try it
you'll love it hellofresh this is good
i like this stuff it's it's it's fun
it's like it's honesty i like that
yeah i like it uh but i do
you know i know it's it's an easy joke
um
what's an easy job well just referring
to you know i didn't think of it as a
joke but
well but it is also really interesting i
do have to say as a
as a woman who's done what i've done
over the last 20 years
to consistently have do you still have
to talk about that
everybody wants to ask me about it and
i'm like do you want to talk about
like a dumb thing you did when you were
when you were essentially a senior in
college yeah believe me if they did i'd
be
yeah you know a lot of dumb stuff your
other career
you have a huge career i just watched
false positive you did
i love false positives very dark my
mother told me to watch it because we
watch horror movies together
wow yeah she's the one who told me to
watch it and what did your mom think of
it
she was like you should watch this false
positive and after i watched i go why
the [ __ ] would you tell me to watch that
that's
so [ __ ] it's pretty dark it is really
dark and your character's dark too what
a twisted uh corrigan
oh god i know but wait before we get to
her this is a fun thing because this is
an easy moment for you to flip to a you
know a joke
or to change the subject so you don't
have to talk about yourself that's how i
do it that's right and i'm like we're
not done
you do it too all right fine but what uh
bastard what did if you feel comfortable
sharing any
part of it what do you what do you think
you were able to communicate in that
letter that gave
you by getting it out of your body and
onto paper that gave you a little bit of
freedom
to have some space for a different kind
of relationship with your dad
i called him out on things that he had
said or done his actions which were
unacceptable
i i felt and ultimately in the letter i
said
you've got a really wonderful kid out
here in california that you could have
so much fun with and spend time with
and actually get to know and you're just
[ __ ] on time
something along those lines and
it took a while and he didn't respond to
me
and then i was like [ __ ] man so then i
shot him an email a couple months later
because we hadn't talked
i go did you get my email he goes yes
all i can say is i love you that was as
you know
such a particular kind of generation
isn't it yeah
he didn't want to get into it didn't
want to he didn't divulge didn't answer
things didn't say
but i um
the thing is i think with him is is a
lot of people
you you have your own problems and
you forget that you're still a father
you forget that you're still you still
have to do the
the right things and you don't have to
follow in your father's footsteps and
you don't have to
and i've done everything i can to not do
that to be
approachable to be loving to be giving
to be all these things not saying my
father is i'm just saying
in general i want to be all these why
are you getting me into the tacos
talking about all this stuff you were
just unpacking stuff because you have a
podcast too
i do drama queens yeah well that's the
second podcast
yeah work in progress is my show that i
started
uh in 2019 that is
you know not dissimilar to this it's
sort of you know
we get into the deep stuff about
incredible people you know culture
leaders and politicians and writers and
actors and comedians and um authors just
everybody out there doing interesting
stuff which is really fun you know i've
interviewed scientists and
um god i'd be so overwhelmed i couldn't
interview a scientist
oh my god i love it i love it all day
but you do the research right
yeah but research is what i do all day
anyway so i finally have been able to
put it into something
which is really fun and and it was off
of doing
work in progress that i
i don't know i have found that there is
such
space for exploration and for healing in
conversation with people for learning
and all of us girls who worked on wintry
hill really have
always carried a thorn in our side since
and i just went you know
what there might be something there one
of one of my
awesome agents asked me if i'd ever
consider you know doing a podcast about
it
kind of as like a covid project a
project about what
about the show about one tree hill
that's what what drama queens is right
yeah and i didn't want to do that by
myself but i sort of chewed on it
and then i called hillary and just said
look i had something suggested to me and
now it's become this idea in my head
and if you hate it you know because she
left first she had a really gnarly
experience with our boss
and i said if you hate it i'll never
speak of it again and we no one ever has
to know that we talked about this but if
you don't hate it i think we should call
joy
she was like paul joy really um and then
the three of us
launched this show and it's
it's so it's so awesome
do you guys get into this stuff too yeah
you talk about your experiences
throughout totally and and i knew we
would
and i knew there would be a lot of
opportunity
like we talked about with this letter to
your dad like to leave it on the page
to get it out of our bodies um and to
to also reminisce on everything that was
so good
because it was all of the things it was
the best of times and the worst of times
as they say
and what i wasn't quite prepared for
was the ways that we were gonna
kind of big sister our younger selves
and each other you know we've been able
to talk about all the things
that we were too scared to bring up back
then
and we've really been able to kind of
come to each other's
rescue and defense and we just laugh
a lot and the coolest part is that
we're finally seeing our show the way
our audience
saw it we'd never done that as a fan in
a way
yeah i you know even if we'd catch an
episode to live tweet or something
we would have just made it it was like
everything was jumbly right
now we are just seeing the episodes
and it's wild and the number of times
we'll all get choked up and we're like
oh man it really hits it hits it's a
really good show
really that's amazing it's really sweet
well you talk about all the stuff that
you guys went through and i know you've
talked about it
a lot i mean and you paint the picture
of that
this guy was the creator of the show was
basically a monster
yeah i mean there's no secret to that no
it's amazing to me how he could be is
so open usually you think that it'd be
one or two people that experience it
but how many people experienced this uh
18 women
on our show signed a collective letter
and that was 18 people willing to be
public about their experiences in the
cast and on the crew
and 25 women on the cast and crew of his
subsequent show
signed a letter in response about his
behavior and it was obvious in front of
the crew
oh yeah he was very open i think the
worst of what he did was hidden
um but yeah he
he was not embarrassed to be handsy to
make inappropriate commentary you just
thought he can get away with it
to pull people into side rooms for
conversations
um to keep
it's funny when you think about the
things that men write you know we would
have these
scenes written for us you know being
with our intimate partners on the show
scenes written where we'd be in our
underwear and whatever and we
found out from a writer that he kept a
board
of the fitting photos of each girl in
underwear up in his office pictures of
us that were taken by the wardrobe
supervisor who was a woman
of us in different versions of underwear
and or lingerie that
that then had to be approved picked and
you know that one would wind up in the
show
he just would keep a board of all these
photos
and we were like wow that's super
violating did anybody ever say
get help dude get [ __ ] help uh yeah
certainly but when someone's in complete
and total control
of 250 people's jobs and livelihoods
it's pretty hard to force them to listen
but it was interesting for us you know
when the show was over uh
really to hear that it was no secret in
the industry either
and he kept working as they all do until
you know this all came out the movement
and then he was fired off royals or
whatever
did you ever do how do you feel if you
ever were face to face with him in a
room
just the two of you to have a
conversation
do you think you could keep your
composure i could do a conversation like
this
you could but even as you asked me to
imagine it like the
sensation of white hot rage in my chest
is not
small because not only was it they
really overt
just abuse and manipulation that he
you know put so many women through but
it was also the more insidious [ __ ]
it was telling me that joy and hillary
were supposedly talking all this [ __ ]
about me and then telling joy that me
and hillary were talking [ __ ] about her
and telling hillary that me and joy were
talking [ __ ] about her
he he all hate each other he pitted us
against each other
and when you're 21 and you're 45 year
old married boss
is telling you that people are coming
into his office to talk about you
you don't think he's making it up and so
the ferocity that i feel
about the time he stole from us
because we clicked fast and we were
really really close
and he didn't like it and it took us a
long time to realize that
you know when he would talk about never
letting us be like the friends cast
we always thought like yeah lol like
what cast is ever gonna get paid that
much money an episode
yeah but what we didn't realize was that
he never wanted us to be
best friends because then we would talk
about money and then we would advocate
together it wouldn't be that kind of
money
but joined forces we would join forces
and we didn't get that at the time we
were kids we didn't know anything about
the business
this was my first tv show you know
hillary had been working on mtv as a vj
like none of us had experience in this
arena
so we didn't we didn't know that we
should have questioned him the most
we we listened to him and we questioned
each other so you
and i find that really unforgivable so
you confided in him you really
trusted him for a while yeah i think
there were periods of time where we all
did
and especially in the earlier years
when he wasn't like as overtly
disgusting
he'd be inappropriate and then he'd like
laugh he'd say oh i don't know anything
i was a dork in high school none of the
girls liked me
like he'd always make these kinds of
excuses it takes a long time to realize
that that's just
an mo but that's not genuine
um and in learning about as the years
went on and he felt more and more
powerful how much more
violent and inappropriate he got with
women
makes it very clear that it was always
you know it was always rooted in the
same
desire to kind of control and conquer
right um but i i just yeah i find it
really unforgivable we could have had a
we could have had the most exquisite
familial experience and
we didn't get to but we get it now
yeah and it's really nice we have it now
we like facetime and cook together and
we get on zoom once a week and we do
this show
yeah that's so ironic i mean it's yeah
you get it now yeah you but you still
get to have that at least
that's a beautiful thing and you know we
always had moments
and then we'd all kind of get a little
nervous you know you'd fall back into
your closeness and then you'd go oh god
am i vulnerable now what does it mean
so it it was like this ebb and flow for
the nine years we did our show and now
it's just flow all the time
and the difference between those two
things is not small
and it's delicious and i love that
this belongs to us you know the three of
us share it equally we're
executive producers it is our show
as a unit of women and we are literally
healing old wounds and you know
if it irks him that we have the power
i'm thrilled
[Laughter]
well said i'm thrilled well said uh this
is called [ __ ] talking
oh with sophia bush as if i didn't just
talk a little bit that was [ __ ] talking
this is [ __ ] talking this is just from
my lovable patrons
oh i love it and they get to ask
questions okay i mean this is kind of a
question that's been asked sophie m can
you tell me whose idea it was to start
the drama queen's podcast it was uh you
know someone came to you and then you
came to the others right yeah i was
having a conversation about
um a a an
imprint of podcasts i wanted to build
out
and i have this amazing agent who's like
you know full gen z
who was just like okay but what if you
did this
and she really sparked the idea for me
and my initial reaction was absolutely
not
and then i sat with it and i was like um
i don't want to do it by myself
i gotta call i gotta call the girl so i
was like i gotta call hillary first
and then she was like call joy and the
best part is we called joy and joe goes
absolutely not and i was like just wait
wait wait wait
because here's my idea you know i think
we were all so
like shuttery about it and i just
you know hillary and i talked to her
about the conversation we'd had you know
when i
when i pitched it to her um and just
said look
we can take it back we can reclaim
all of it together and then she was like
wait a second this is cool
and uh and it's interesting the way that
the three of us can
as a unit advocate for each other and
when one person gets understandably
nervous about something
we can come together and talk about it
and solve for it and
and yeah so it's it's been it's been
great
nancy d what is what's the one role that
you would drop everything to play or one
director you drop everything to work
with
oof um i would drop
everything to work with
tyka with ryan coogler
with zoe lister jones
oh i
i would i just want to play a superhero
guys
you do huh yeah yeah like i'm scrappy
and i'm a good stunt driver and i'm very
proficient with weapons and i'd like to
do some wire work
i've seen black widow twice i think it
is so good
i love it i haven't seen it oh it is
so all right all right good it's so good
and i'm just like
i want to do this you should do it i
think you will we'll see
i guess yeah kelly asked is there an
accurate actress that you were inspired
by while growing up
um say meryl streep
well i mean look of course obviously
meryl is like duh
everyone but i'm trying to think you
know
in high school i i think i became
like a full die hard kate blanchett stan
you know i just think she's so
unbelievably talented and and
you know obviously meryl and kate have
been women who i
i just love to watch and and
god viola davis i mean she just came in
so hot and is so
exquisite and i mean there's so many
women who i
who i learn from watching but
man i think in in terms of people who
can just make me feel like they've
ripped my heart out of my chest those
three really are top tier
those are good ones uh stephae just said
learned a lot from your work in progress
podcast thank you for using your voice
for good you're a real inspiration
thanks steph little lisa says you have
any funny behind-the-scenes stories from
john tucker must die
oh my god we had so much
fun on that movie oh man
um i have a lot of stories i can't tell
any of you
but really yeah we just had a ball
we had an absolute ball but what was
really fun
um while we were working up there my
sweet angel britney snow
wound up um adopting this cute little
dog
and so suddenly we had a set dog which
was heavenly because
i i was really missing my dogs that
summer um
so it was really nice we got a little a
little mascot that's a little behind the
scenes for you
the last question is will you train
michael's dog
i mean i can give you some tips because
you really are good you're very there's
something about you that's just very
i mean right when you walked in you just
my dog kind of jumped on you and you're
you're
you're patient you seem like you're just
your whole disposition your whole you
just seem relaxed i don't know what it
is i i i wish i had more of that
you just seem relaxed are you relaxed
no okay so i was wrong i'm completely
wrong
i am very type a i'm high stress
and probably a bit high strung
but the place where i get
really grounded and still is in good
conversation
so well you're welcome you're welcome i
was going to say thank you
i'm kidding i'm going to say so i feel
very relaxed now
thank you this guy interrupting let me
let me get to the point i know i do that
sometimes
but i i think that it's also part of the
reason that i love
hosting the shows so much is because i
i do i feel really
like grounded when when we do this
yeah i like her ryan i think she's she's
a good she's an inspiration
you are you're you're you're a good
woman you're a
good human being thanks yeah there's
something just i feel comfortable when
i'm talking to you i think the audience
will say the same thing there's just you
speak your mind you're very confident
but you're also realistic and you're
honest and sweet
thank you i'll throw sweet in there
thanks but uh this has been a great time
i really enjoyed this did you have a
good time i did it was
it was i really like talking to you i'm
glad you finally came in here and uh
maybe one little trick for blanche
before we leave
yeah she was sitting for you i know she
was staying for her
she doesn't stay for anyone you gotta
make yourself clear
that's the thing that i think is really
helpful is if you can start working on
them to sit do you do any hand motions
with her
i do a snap i go sit down
interesting sit down interesting
this is why i love talk shows yeah um oh
my god do you want to know the most
embarrassing thing that i have ever
done uh yeah for sure and his wife and i
laugh about it
thank god she's my friend so the first
week that seth meyers was ever on
late night i went on i was one of his
guests in the first week i've never
never been more flattered by anything i
just love him i think he's amazing
and i was working in chicago and having
like an extra miserable time
at work and uh which is no secret to
anybody
which is why i think i've busted my ass
in the last couple of years to make such
good projects with such wonderful people
like false positive working with alana
working with women and really good dudes
and
and gearing up to go shoot good sam my
new show which is
all you know helmed by incredible women
and the men who've come in are
phenomenal and
um because you know i went from a show
where every time our boss was in town it
sucked to working on a show that like
sucked most of the time
for me as a woman shocker quit right
before me too hit the news that was fun
um but i was working there
and reading i was reading amy fuller's
book one weekend
my best friend had come in to visit me
and we've gone
to the rooftop of the soho house in
chicago we were like laying by the pool
it was summertime
and we were having rose and like i don't
i'm sensitive to things guys i'd
probably had two glasses of rose
everyone else was tipsy i was hammered
and i'm reading amy poehler's book just
crying laughing at how sweet it is and
then i get to the chapter that seth
meyers wrote
about being her friend and looking up to
her and what it was like to be supported
by her and how it made him feel like he
could do anything
and i had been texting with seth and
with his wife alexi
um just about like charity stuff in new
york
and i in my semi-drunken stupor sent
seth meyer as a text message
saying hey i'm reading amy's book and
laughing crying and now i've read your
chapter and i'm crying
and i just want you to know that like
even in the boosts that you give to
people who come on your show like me
when you tell them they're great and you
love their work you make us feel like
amy made you feel and i sent it
i sent it guys oh that's nice though
i was like oh no well what's wrong with
that and then there was like a bubble
and then it went away and then there was
a bubble and it was like oh [ __ ] and the
next day i looked at my phone and i was
like so sorry about the daytime rose
yesterday
and then i was chatting with his wife we
do a lot of advocacy for women together
and i was like so i did this really
embarrassing thing reading amy paul's
book
and i drunk texted seth about how he's
like a leader for people and a great
ally to women and she was like
oh god he doesn't know how to feel
feelings like that and we were just like
dying laughing himself i could just see
his face
trying to text you back like i really
appreciate i don't know what the [ __ ] to
say
this is what happens i do conversations
like this i'm not really the person
people come to for a quippy one-liner
and when you're one of the world's
greatest comedians like comedy is what
you do
and so next time i saw him i was just
like hey dude
next time i'll send you a joke
well you know that's fine that's cool
i'm sure he appreciated it
and see that if we were in fact doing
late night which is what the callback
was all about would be a great late
night story
yeah i like that and i think it was
sweet i don't know i i wouldn't feel
uncomfortable like oh my god thank you
so much
she's drunk that's so cool yeah
that's what i do i'm such a good time i
get drunk and read books
yeah that's the cool girl that's the
girl
this is why i like to interview science
people yes yeah good for you
well hey so two podcasts work in
progress drama queens
yeah uh listen to them both i mean she's
uh really enjoyable to listen to
and uh what other projects you have
going on oh gosh well false positive
just came out what's positive on netflix
so creepy i'm so sorry really watch you
know how i love horror movies it's
creepy
you're gonna dig it pierce brosnan ah
can you believe
how scary he's so he's just it's just
bizarre he's just fabulous he's bizarre
he's terrible he's terrifyingly he's
just so
nice so without giving away the end that
story
has happened multiple times okay
i can't even uh-huh that's where the
whole thing comes from we were gonna end
the movie oh my god we were gonna end
the movie with pictures of all the
doctors who've been caught
don't say anything with pictures of all
those kinds of doctors and we were told
we weren't allowed to for legal reasons
but yeah
it's [ __ ] and now you really want to
listen to it and she's really good you
play a really cool character that you're
it's there's a nice twist to it
and i'm so glad i watched that thanks
yeah yeah she's a she's a strange kind
of villain
and i didn't watch it because you were
coming on the podcast i watched it
randomly and you were love that
like oh she's in this oh cool oh i love
that well tell your mom i said thanks
i will so yeah that just came out it's
streaming on hulu and then good sam
uh here's another callback for you the
irony
good sam the show on which i play a
heart surgeon
is coming out on cbs in january really
yeah we came full circle heart surgeon
your dad will be proud you're a fake
heart surgeon
yeah i love it i've been i've been
shadowing surgeons and actually
i know observing in the o.r and
open heart surgery is the coolest thing
i've ever seen oh my god
changed my life it's the coolest
experience i have ever maybe you'll quit
everything and be a heart surgeon it's
not too late you're still young
could you imagine i could actually can
you imagine that i think you could do
whatever you want to do
well i appreciate that if you had a
choice right now to be the top heart
surgeon or a top superhero what would it
be
can i be the superhero now and like go
to med school in 10 years can i do
that sure you could do that but you
might get tired at 40 i don't even know
i don't know
i don't feel like i'd get tired i'm
tired right now talking about it
you're tired of thinking about being a
superhero or being a surgeon no talking
about being a surgeon oh my god i
couldn't even imagine all the years of
school and
i could barely get through school as it
was you know it was
i have to be interested if occasionally
you had a great teacher that would keep
your interest
somebody who really loved what they were
doing and you saw that and had an
interest in you
and those were always the best teachers
and they were rare they were few and far
between
yeah but um anyway and what's your
handles by the way
oh it's nothing i don't have like a fun
name on the internet it's just my name
it's just at
sofia bush you heard that follow the
girl will ya
this has been a real treat thank you and
uh i love having you on you're welcome
anytime
thank you and i hope you'll hopefully
you'll post when this is out so you
could listen to it because i think it's
a great conversation you just let me
know
the day and and yeah we should get
blanche and maggie on a walk i would
love that maggie i'll teach her a thing
or two oh i would love that yeah and
blanche is really good with other dogs
yeah yeah yeah
great i mean she gets excited yeah i
mean same okay good
i get excited and so does maggie good
say goodbye to ryan
ryan sofia it's been a pleasure
i'm learning guys you are you're doing a
great job yeah look at that
right at the mic wow
what did you like about sofia ryan i
didn't like
that everyone kept making fun of me for
my mic skills your mic skills
i know how to use a mic guys guys
i promise yeah we were giving him [ __ ] a
little bit but
uh but she was very nice she was very
good she is she was really just really
quick had a lot to say and said it and
uh spoke her mind and uh
i think that's what you see is what you
get with sophia bush and uh
so look thank you for listening thank
you for uh if you really enjoyed that
episode i hope you'll um
subscribe to the podcast you'll follow
us on our handles at insideapot on
twitter and
inside you podcast on facebook and
instagram and all that jazz
um thank you for everyone for um coming
to the stage at last week and watching
my band sunspin play two shows
it was a real treat join patreon don't
forget
support the podcast i'll message you
right away after you join usually within
a few days and
that's patreon.com inside you join the
patreon family
today and the inside of you online store
tons of great merch
and the sunspin store where you can get
tons of band merch like the shirt i'm
wearing this
sunspin shirt just go to sunspin.com
uh for that uh patreons without you i've
said it before i can't really do this
show
you guys make it happen and i'm gonna
read off the top tier patrons that get
packages from me every couple of months
and um special notes from me and a bunch
of other perks
well let's just do it right now um nancy
d
leah s tricia
f sarah v little lisa yukiko jill
e brian h mama cass
well no mama g oh that's a new one mama
g i think it is a new one unless it's
mama lauren and i didn't know that but
whatever but mama g nico p
jerry w robert b jason w apothean
kristen k
amelia oh allison l raj c joshua d
emily s cj p god you're good ryan
you know you're good at this yeah you
have a good memory samantha m jennifer
and stacey l
jen s jamal f janelle b mike e l don
supremo 99 more ramirez santiago m
sarah f chad w liam p janine r ray a
maya
p mattie s shannon d god
how does he do it randomly like that
matt w belinda n
james r chris h dave h spider-man chase
sheila g brad uh h
d d ray h tabitha t tom and liliana a
michelle k
michael s talia m betsy ross
d oh that was the flag woman wasn't it
was the fight cd
yes uh yeah you know the flag woman you
know the flag woman yeah
the flags claire m laura l chad l
rochelle
nathan e marion meg cage in lp
ah jeddah lorraine g you weren't here
last week and i had to read it myself
and i think i messed that up
no you did yeah i'm a messer upper
veronica k big stevie w
kendall t carol d angel m rhiannon c
corey k
super sam super sam i used to go to that
store all the time
emily c coleman g dev nixon michelle a
liz l
jeremy c andy t cody r sebastian k
gavinator david c
elliott m john b brandy d yvore bono
urbano patrick case h and joey
m thank you you lovely patrons for
making this show possible
and uh you um subscribing to patreon
like i said over and over really does
wonders for the show and keeps us
ticking and we want to keep on doing
this show um i certainly enjoy it
and uh ryan did you have a good week i
know you were you had to isolate since i
tested positive and you had isolate for
14 days
i mean i know it's not my fault but were
you mad at me at all yes
you were uh-huh why because i don't
think anyone should have been at your
house
what do you mean i would have to include
this but no i don't think no it's okay
let's talk about it no
um no i think uh if you were feeling
shitty on tuesday
wednesday and wednesday and you took the
test on thursday and i was negative
but you took the pcr and i came in on
friday that came in friday but i was i
was
here hear me out honest to god i
wouldn't had anybody here and the reason
why i had somebody here
is because i was feeling tired and i
just had back surgery and i was still on
pain meds
and i'm still like you know recovering
so wednesday i was a little fatigued
but nothing nothing major at all
thursday
still just a little fatigued so i didn't
feel
and by the way my symptoms only
were extreme fatigue it just got worse
and worse
until i was finally like there's no way
i could have
i'm vaccinated i'm just tired i just was
in houston it's two hours ahead
in my mind i really felt like there's no
way i have coveted there's just no
[ __ ] way
i was pretty pretty good in houston they
had a plexiglass in front of me
so just to you know let you understand
if i had congestion and sore
throat and swollen lymph nodes and all
these things i didn't lose my sense of
smell or taste
so it wasn't until i got that test i was
like i can't
and what happened i went and got tested
again immediately because i didn't i
didn't know if i believed it
i thought it was a false positive so
that's why i got tested again
immediately the next day thinking
there's
you know and then friday night i started
to feel more tired and saturday
and i felt like wow this is a fatigue
that i haven't had
so i really apologize but i but i really
didn't believe i had it
yeah and i was i was thinking you know
at first
it just didn't cross my mind that i had
covered when you're vast you just don't
think
you know i'm pretty cautious and i
didn't get it for a year and a half i
just didn't think i was gonna get it and
i didn't have these extreme symptoms
i just was really tired and i thought
i'm just [ __ ]
tired that's why i got tested on
thursday
and when that first test came back
negative i go of course i'm negative and
the guy goes it's 96
effective and i'm like all right i'm
just tired or if anything maybe have a
cold
do you hear me out yeah are you still
mad i mean it was it was a rough week it
was a rough week man
it was just uh it was not something i
really needed to
to be dealing with and i know you had
the whole disease and i'm sorry you had
it and it sounded really shitty and it
sounded
shitty um i guess at the time i was sort
of feeling like
well if he was feeling shitty early in
the week where there's no way we should
have been here unmasked
there's just no way we should have been
here well again
it it didn't feel like i had anything
other than fatigue
in fact like i said for the next 12 days
what did i have
extreme fatigue that's it no other
symptoms
so if i started to get a sore throat and
i started to feel these things i'd be
like [ __ ] guys i'm sick
i'm not gonna be in front of people when
i'm sick but the fact that it was
negative and it was fatigue and i just
had gotten back and it was my first trip
and i was tired
you don't realize my back was all
swollen
when i was there so it's constantly
icing down which made me feel like [ __ ]
i was just constantly running around
and i just felt like i was just drained
yeah i never thought for a second that i
had covered
yeah i mean i swear to god i did not
think i had covet
i mean i'll just say like it was very
i'll just say what it was like for me
was just very
sudden and all like immediately just
sort of felt like
[ __ ] uh
this this this is really gonna [ __ ]
everything up so i had to
call amanda on my way home and said okay
so michael just got a test
a positive test for cobit and um i'm
going home she's like
[ __ ] i still have auditions to do so i
went into my apartment because my
our closet is the recording studio right
so right because we had to turn that
like into covet so
i just i went into my i went into my
apartment i showered i
stayed masked the whole time she came in
masked she finished her auditions and
then she sort of like
took some food out of the fridge and was
like well [ __ ] bye
and so she just said because she had to
go to her place and she um
and you had 14 days of yeah and she's 10
days later so yeah so she
she lost the the recording booth she had
her microphone but she's had a lot of
sound quality
and um and that was kind of a big bummer
for her
and um and then
i mean this is obviously not your fault
but this is just something that really
shittily happened like while we were
quarantining
um one of her
her childhood friend just [ __ ] died
from covid not coveted not even coveted
he died
in a car accident in france
and she it was it was killer
just all of a sudden she got a text one
morning and um
i was super bummed because i couldn't
comfort her i couldn't comfort her the
way i needed to
and uh it's i mean it's obviously
it's part of the isolation process it
was just really i mean
this shouldn't like happen ever but it
was just really shitty timing and she
was just three times
she's [ __ ] mess still uh the funerals
today
oh i'm so sorry man so that was just
sort of it was just
one sort of thing one thing after
another yeah and she also she had like a
big job on tuesdays so like pretty much
like the second i called her she's like
well i gotta
[ __ ] off because it's a i have a job
like a huge like
job in three days i i was just baffled
by the whole [ __ ] thing
i was baffled because for a year and a
half uh
i didn't get it and i was very careful
and then i get vast
and then then i randomly get it
and let me tell you guys something i
will say this
thank god i was vast because i feel like
if i wasn't vast
i probably would have gone to the
hospital i
felt like i couldn't move by the next
week it wasn't even until the next week
where i
started to feel really bad that was like
wednesday that following week where i
just
it was one of these things where you're
just lying there and you know you have
to eat because you haven't eaten all day
and you're like
i can't i can't i can't even go upstairs
i can't even go and post many times i
still have the strength to go on
postmates
or something i'm just so tired i
remember the guy at the door i postmates
knocked and he stood there and i go hey
you can just leave it there he goes
hello i go you could just leave it there
he goes well i just want to make sure i
go hey buddy i have covered dude and he
just [ __ ] took off
i was like dude get the [ __ ] out of here
well i'm sorry about all this
i mean if i can go back in time and
really think that i
you know had it i i never would have
done that friday i certainly would have
had an interview i mean it was you know
if i thought i had [ __ ] covered
it was the last thing i thought i had
and uh
it's just a drag this whole situation is
a drag but you know
i feel really safe now now that i've had
it and i'm vast it's like i'm almost
super vaxxed in a way
yeah but you know you still gotta be you
know we have a rule now i mean we had a
rule anyway it's like you're not coming
in here unless you're vaxxed
and that's just you know goes you know
we have a guest that's coming in next
week and you know you're not facts
you're not coming in
i was surprised to hear that potential
guest is not in fact so surprised about
that yeah we don't have to bring that up
i won't but yes
yeah i know i just don't get it i don't
get it especially when you're working in
this industry you sort of
i think you have to be vast yeah i won't
include that but
i don't have to include it no you can't
include it you can put the whole thing
if you want
people are either listening or not you
don't have to you know
by this point they're gone anyway don't
you agree
you guys are still listening we just got
into a little conversation about this
and i thought it was
healthy and it was real and it was you
know it was
what's going on in the world and uh
so there you have it it's scary get
[ __ ] bad get vaccinated
please get vaccinated for your own
benefit for people around you
um you don't know how you're gonna
respond
i'm pretty healthy you know and
i felt like i was about a day away from
going to the hospital i
felt like i just can't function as a
human being
and and you know then my doctor said
take a z-pack do this and then it turned
around for me
i took a z-peck loaded up in vitamin c
vitamin d zinc
all these other things and three days
later it just completely turned around
and
um but yeah do yourselves a favor you
don't you don't wanna
you don't wanna yeah doesn't give a [ __ ]
kobe doesn't care who you are
yeah you could be as healthy as a
[ __ ] fiddle is that what you say fit
as a fiddler
as a healthy as a [ __ ] ham hawk of
ham
guys thank you for listening and uh
uh we we love you and we really
appreciate you tuning in um from myself
michael rosenbaum
and myself ryan tears uh there's a
camera up there from the hollywood hills
in uh
california california we uh we love you
and we thank you for listening
and we'll talk to you soon thank you for
allowing me to be inside of each and
every one of you